تداعيات التقارب التركيه السوري مستمره
خصوصا بعد اعلان دمشق موافقه التركيه على
الانسحاب الكامل من شمال سوريا
الامر الذي اثار حفيظه الاكراد امام هذه
التطورات ترى مثل ريهاد التي تنتظر
الاكراد انقره تريد القضاء على التهديد
الكردي قرب حدودها بينما تسع روسيا الى
تصفيه حليف للولايات المتحده في سوريا اما
النظام السوري في يريد السيطره على
الاراضي وخصوصا الثروات النفطيه من
الاكراد في شمال شرقي البلاد اقتراب
الاتفاق الثلاثي يضعوا الاكراد الذي لا
تصدقوا بشراسه خلال سنوات السوري لتنظيم
داعش امام خيارات احلها مره ففي حال رفض
الاكراد تلبيه مطلب انقره المتجدد
بالانسحاب لمسافه 30 كلم عن الحدود فان
التقارب الثلاثيه ذلك سيشكل محركا لح
تركيا هناك وللرئيس التركي ما يشجع على
ذلك
فانتصاره في حال خاض حربا هناك قد يقوي من
موقفه قبيل موعد الانتخابات التركيه يونيو
المقبل وسط دعوات الاوروبيه لتركيا بضروره
التفريق بين حزب العمال الكردستاني
والاكراد
اهداف مختلفه وطريق واحد تاتي تفاهمات
الدول الثلاث مفجره قلق لدى الاكراد خشيه
التضحيه بهم وان يدفعوا الثمن التقارب
والتصالح حربا شديده على الارض
عصام عبد السلام العربيه